las familias de los pasajeros de los
cuatro aviones secuestrados por al qaeda
para los atentados del 11 de septiembre
acordaron no demandar a las aerolíneas
era un mundo distinto sin protocolos que
permitieron a los extremistas ingresar
armas blancas a las aeronaves se
ajustaron los filtros de seguridad y no
se permitió ingresar con cuchillos o
tijeras en el equipaje de mano se
instalaron los equipos especiales para
revisar las maletas lo que alargó las
filas y tiempos de abordaje llegaron los
escáner 360° aumentaron las máquinas de
rayos x los detectores de armas y de
explosivos además se aumentaron los
precios para facturar el equipaje y se
implementaron otros cargos extra por
servicios y se hizo obligatorio pasar
por el escáner el 100% del equipaje de
bodega antes se hacía sólo
aleatoriamente también se prohibió a las
personas que no fueran a viajar ingresar
a la sala de espera y se creó la
administración de seguridad de
transporte que obliga a las aerolíneas a
entregar información de cada pasajero
dentro del avión las puertas de cabina
de los pilotos fueron blindadas para
hacer frente a las pérdidas en vuelos
que alcanzaron los 55 mil millones de
dólares durante el 2001 varias
aerolíneas comerciales se fusionaron se
estima que las compañías aéreas
perdieron durante la pandemia de kobe
1921 mil millones de dólares menos de la
mitad que hace 20 años